okay so today we are going to be
reacting to something that Kevin Samuel
said before he passed so um when Kevin
Sam and this is rest in peace Kevin
Samuels um yeah yeah so um great man
great man but this is something that he
said before he passed away that when he
passed had a lot of people in uproar so
um we are going to react to the clip if
you could pull it up-ish
and give our thoughts
okay but if you have made it to 35 years
old and you're unmarried
you are a leftover woman
a leftover woman you are what is left
men know that there's something likely
wrong with you whether you want to hear
it or not I'm going to just go there
with you I'm telling you the truth that
you don't want to hear men know that
there is something likely wrong with you
but you cannot be fit in a an adjustable
six or higher 35 unmarried something
wrong with you
that's where men automatically coming at
it and here's the thing just like when
you were between the ages of 18 and uh
25 and you didn't want to settle you
were trying to get them you were trying
to get the CEO the pilot the investment
banker you were trying to get food out
here's what's going to happen if you are
a woman 35 Plus
foreign
that's on the same lifestyle level
you're going to have to share it so I
want to start and give your initial
thoughts to this video starting with you
and then go around
starting with me
35
you're left over
so you're done out here
I disagree wholeheartedly with what are
you saying oh you disagree no I agree oh
you agree you'll just agree so you think
it's over at
35. you know there's all these people
calling themselves tens I'm just curious
how old are you 40 40. so how was how
old would you date younger
how about would I date yeah yeah
30 30. okay is that is that how old your
girlfriend is no oh okay my missus is my
age oh okay we're big people out here
okay yeah I was just wondering yeah yeah
yeah no worries
okay what about you
um
I personally disagree
um I'm 21 so I don't have that much
experience in like the relation Dating
Game and everything like that but I feel
like in my generation and like moving
forward
um I don't think that's possible because
it's like we have people that are like
public figures for example like
just to use an example like Kim
Kardashian she's like 40 years old
and she's still dating she was in a
relationship like she was married for
like how long and it's like outside of
that you know her breaking up with her
husband and everything
she's still like kind of moving on still
dating I don't think 35 is I think 35 is
too young for you to say that you're
left over
I feel like I saw a bit too young but
that's just my opinion okay what do you
think
um I don't think I agree with the term
leftover in general and I also don't
think you should put an age on what your
term as left over
um I think it's I think age is
irrelevant I think it's completely based
on who you are character
all the different other attributes aside
from age like just to say because
someone's a certain age they're left
over women I think that's I completely
disagree completely disagree that's my
stance
I agree you agree why as a woman I agree
because most women over 35 who are
single of issues okay I was 35 at one
point and I had issues like you know
they've got issues I mean you're 35.
even
if you're a virgin
I can't understand right or then you're
not left over but if you're 35 and
you've lived life
and you've been through life
why should a man want you I mean
everybody's looking at all these artists
and all these Stars that's not reality
that's just one-off but at 35
I had issues at 35 so I can understand
that if you're not married at 35 or in a
stable relationship has to be something
wrong with you otherwise why aren't you
in a relationship if you're that great
you go ahead what do you guys think um
but in the in the video that we saw he
didn't say relationship per se he said
if you're not married so would you say
it's different if you're in a
relationship that if you're good enough
to be in a long-term relationship you're
good enough to get married and if you're
not why aren't you not everybody aspires
to marriage though that's very true
that's the problem I don't necessarily
think it's a problem I just think that
it's a different I think over the
different Generations there's different
views for instance a lot of the women
and girls I speak to my age say they put
off marriage and having children till
they're in their 30s so I think times
have changed in terms of for instance
myself
I would consider a marriage in my 30s
like and if I got to 35 and I wasn't
married I wouldn't I wouldn't
necessarily see it as a problem and that
there's something wrong with me
um yeah I see I think just assuming that
there's something wrong with someone
that's not married at 35 is just
I think it's oversimplifying everything
and I completely disagree again
wouldn't you say though it's it's if you
wouldn't you want to be married if there
was a guy that had checked all your
boxes
would you not would you not want to
marry him
I mean if I feel like if it made sense
then yeah I don't feel like people
should well firstly I don't think people
should rush into marriage firstly like I
feel like
you should like kind of take time when
it comes to that kind of stuff but yeah
like if I have found someone that
literally tooks all my boxes and all of
that stuff 100 now so then by that logic
wouldn't you say that the the women that
aren't picked by 35 like the best guys
picked the younger women and left
everyone else over
like in a way because because if you
survey men between the ages of 20 and 80
and you ask like what age do they find
the most attractive all of them find the
ages between like 21 to 24. it's like a
girl's Peak
and um 90 of your eggs are gone by 30
and 50 of your options are gone by 30.
I wouldn't say you should say there's a
peak time I feel like when you're saying
there's a peak time you're basing it or
looks primarily
um I think there's so much more like you
don't marry someone just based on looks
and between the ages of 21 to 24 that
could be your Peak but you're finding
yourself so how can you say that okay A
man should pick a woman at that age but
she doesn't even know who she is yet I
feel like one once you put an age on
these things that's where like divorce
tends to come in divorce rates are so
high I think because you're paying and
you're paying time pressure on it I
don't think there needs to be a time
pressure and sorry going back to your
point about if a guy ticked all my boxes
now again I wouldn't say that I'm ready
um because I feel like I'm still finding
myself at the age of 21.
um you haven't experienced life you
haven't done a lot of things and again
this is why I don't think age should be
the fact what we measure it by because
someone could be 35 and they haven't
experienced life as much as someone
who's
25 and that's a 10 10 year age Gap and
they could have had completely different
life experiences so yeah I think my
problem is putting a Time on it so in
terms of age I think that's where the
problem is so do you not think it starts
with looks
yeah I think it starts but it will stop
at a certain point like it will not be
long lasting if it's just based
primarily on looks so